foreign
[Music]
hey you guys here we are once again with
tomes of Terror this is my little book
review Series so this week's read was
another result of what I've taken to
calling Kindle unlimited roulette uh I'm
basically just uh scrolling through
whatever the recommended horror titles
are and choosing a book at random that
has you know a cool cover and or an
intriguing title
so the one that I chose for this week is
called a place so wicked by Patrick
rumin it's it I'm not really sure if
it's Roman or royman
so you know I apologize I'm hoping one
of those two is right uh this book was
actually published in the early spring
of 2021.
and although going into it and when I
read it when I was reading it I thought
that I had never read any of this
author's work before however after I
finished it and when I was like going
back and researching his catalog I
realized that not too long ago I had
actually read one of his other books and
reviewed it matter of fact uh it was his
more recent novel
um the Adirondack witch which came out
in this year of like 2022. now that book
I liked it but I didn't love it it was
kind of like a Blair Witch unreliable
narrator lost in the woods type of thing
with like a little bit of a surreal
thing
um you know and I have a review of that
so I'm not gonna like rehash it here but
I would just suffice it to say that I
had read one of this guy's books before
I just didn't remember but like I said I
read a lot of things it's like you know
what I mean to be honest I kind of had
the same reaction to a place so wicked
as I did to the Adirondack which I think
I liked this one slightly better because
it was a haunted house story and I
really really like haunted house stories
but I still had like some of the same
issues with it maybe that I and
countered with the Adirondack which so
I'll get into that in a little bit so a
place so wicked has a pretty standard
you know like haunted house type of
setup so there's a family whose last
names I realize that I don't remember
and I think maybe their last names were
only mentioned a couple of times and
they might have been different each time
if maybe that's why I can't remember
them I could be wrong about that but
yeah it doesn't really matter anyway so
it's like a family Richard and Lisa are
the mom and dad there's also an uncle
who is the dad's brother his name is
Robbie and he's helping them move and
hoping that he's going to be able to
stay with them in their new house for a
while because I guess like his
girlfriend just kicked him out and then
there are three teenage kids uh you have
Toby who's 16 and then there are a set
of 13 year old like fraternal twins
Trevor and Paisley
now just like in the Adirondack witch
which is one of the little niggling
things that I had about that uh there
are a couple of sets of character names
that start with the same letter
um you know you got Richard Robbie you
got Trevor Toby that kind of stuff but
at least here like the characters are
distinct enough that I didn't usually
have trouble telling them apart I think
I kind of kind of had a problem in
Adirondack which because I think there
were two character names that started
with Jay or actually maybe it was three
character names that started with Jay
and like they weren't really like
distinct enough and I kept forgetting
who was who but that's not really that
much of an issue here so anyway like the
dad Richard Works in it I think and he's
taken a new job in this tiny little kind
of like map spec of a town called black
Falls which I think is in Upstate New
York now of course all of the kids are
bummed out that they're moving out
essentially like to the middle of
nowhere and especially Toby who is kind
of like not bullied or anything like
that but he's just kind of like shy and
not really all that popular and he feels
as though like it is old school he had
just gotten to this sort of satisfactory
place where he had a couple of close
friends and he could remain kind of like
relatively Anonymous and like blend into
the background which was fine with him
and now he's like well [ __ ] now I'm
gonna have to start all over again what
everybody thinks I'm a loser you know
just like the regular stuff that a
teenage boy would think moving to a new
town now weirdly Richard the dad is
really really enthused about moving
specifically to Black Falls telling his
family multiple times this town is
supposedly like one of the best
up-and-coming towns in the United States
it's gonna be the perfect place to live
so awesome it's even established that he
had gotten like a whole bunch of other
job offers maybe some of which were more
lucrative uh and they were like in
larger cities just so he could
specifically move here now the 16 year
old son Toby whose POV were mostly
following at the beginning of the story
although the POV character I'm gonna say
right here changes wildly and without
much mourning which I'll get into like a
little bit more later he actually finds
it strange as you probably would that
his dad is so gung-ho about this place
in particular but when they arrive in
town he does have to admit that oh there
is something really kind of nice about
this place something that he can't
really quite put his finger on like when
they first get there like they kind of
go through their realistic of barbecue
and everybody's like waving at them like
everybody seems really friendly and
really welcoming initially and even when
they get to their house it's this
massive house like way bigger than any
he said it looked like a manor house and
it's just like really really gorgeous
it's all been done out and everything
pretend better yet at least from Toby's
point of view uh there's a gorgeous girl
named Addison or Addie for short who is
the same age as him and she lives across
the street and immediately seems kind of
like flirtatious and like interested in
him so Toby starts to think hey maybe
this move isn't going to be so bad after
all but not too long after that of
course uh odd little things start
happening like for example when Toby is
out mowing the lawn he discovers that
the grass has actually been painted
green like the real grass underneath is
dry and dead and like the soil is kind
of weird and black there's even like a
tree in the front yard that somebody
seemingly meticulously painted to look
like it was alive even though it is also
like gray and dead
the dead grass like seems to surround
the house like out to a certain distance
and then the grass gets normal again
like outside this perimeter there's also
like this really weird Eerie like
Stillness and like quietness on their
street in particular though it seems
like most of the other streets in town
are normal
um there's also the weird fact that
people keep leaving like casseroles and
like other food like on the front porch
of their house but nobody like knocks or
acknowledges the gifts they just kind of
like leave the food and then like
skedaddle which is like really really
weird Lisa the mom at one point she goes
to the house next door to like
investigate like hey why the hell is
like somebody just like creeping up on
our porch and leaving food there that's
really weird
um you know this cool Phantom food
phenomenon but she discovers when she
does that that the house next door is
actually completely empty and most of
the other ones on their street in
particular seem deserted as well so the
family also noticed a horrible like
overwhelming stench that is emanating
from a locked room with a red door in
the basement so the smell is so bad that
at times it just kind of like permeates
the whole entire house making them all
gag and like none of them can really eat
all that much because they you know
don't have any appetite because the
house smells so bad
um Richard and Robbie you know the dad
and uncle they want to get into the
locked basement room and find out like
maybe an animal died in there maybe
several animals died in there we gotta
like clean that out like to get rid of
this [ __ ] smell but they keep calling
the realtor to be like hey do you have
that key and the realtor keeps giving
them like the run around no no I never
could find that I'll look for it I'll
get back to you but it's been like weeks
and weeks and he just seems like he's
blowing them off so Richard and Robbie
then try to force the door open but
weirdly the door doesn't have any hinges
to remove and really kind of like
refuses to be pried open it's just kind
of like it's almost like it was built
into this door like it's exactly the
right size you know what I mean so
there's like no hinges or no anything so
as The Story Goes On on each of the
family members starts falling horribly
horribly ill like first Trevor he's one
of the twins then Robbie the uncle then
the parents Richard and Lisa
um Toby and Paisley seem to evade this
mysterious illness though probably they
established because they spend more time
away from the house than any of the
other family members
um Toby actually starts exploring this
burgeoning romance with Addison so he's
kind of out with her all the time as
well as her really weird and sort of
surly best friend whose name is Robert I
think and Paisley the 13 year old she
kind of strikes up a friendship with a
14 year old boy named Eli who she meets
at this otherwise like abandoned looking
playground but like behind his house now
at one stage Toby very clearly sees what
is undoubtedly a ghost like in the Attic
it looks like a woman who looks really
terrified and looks like she's trying to
force open the Attic Window to jump out
and it like replays like over and over
again at varying other times he and some
of the other characters like see a whole
bunch of apparitions like a whole bunch
of people are like peering out through
the Windows like when they're outside so
there's that too so basically as events
kind of start coming to a head Toby and
Paisley realize that they're going to
have to be the ones to step up and like
figure out what exactly is going on here
as the rest of their family are
essentially have fallen like horribly
horribly deathly ill like can't even get
out of bed they're just like puking
their guts out they look like they're
just at death's door and really the few
other people in town that are actually
willing to talk to them are starting to
act somewhat Sinister
um I won't spoil exactly what is
happening like with this house and the
town but suffice it to say that it has
something to do with like the door in
the basement which is kind of like I
guess holding back some kind of like
evil force so as I mentioned this is a
pretty solid like Haunted House story
something particularly original but it
was pretty fast-paced and some pretty
entertaining I will say I really really
liked the initial build up of the
weirdness like especially [ __ ] like um
The Painted dead grass and the Unseen
neighbors like leaving the casseroles
like that kind of stuff is really creepy
to me just because it's so random and
it's so lacking context and it isn't
really like overtly threatening it's
just odd and like to me like that kind
of stuff is way creepier than stuff
that's more overtly scary you know what
I'm saying I mean obviously something
terrible is behind that scary basement
door has been done millions of times
before and I was like hell um I just
read another novel not too long ago
called The Exorcist house that had a
similar thing going on that had like
some creepy thing in the basement that
everybody was like trying to keep in
there but you know I didn't really mind
that all that much basements are creepy
so you know a lot of stories kind of
revolve around that and I will admit
that I was very interested like to see
where this mystery was going to go even
though it's not it doesn't have like a
lot of twists and turns you know what I
mean like you're pretty clear like where
it's gonna go and any given time that
said though I did kind of feel like
there was something a little bit lacking
about this story like and it's kind of
like hard for me to put my finger on
like the explanation behind the house
and the town at large was conceptually
kind of cool if I mean it's not that all
that unique but it was actually like
kind of cool but I kind of wish it had
been fleshed out more I mean I'm usually
and I say this a lot I'm usually an
advocate of not explaining your
mythology or your monster or anything
like that too much of like leaving some
things to your reader's imagination but
I will say though that I think maybe
this story aired on the side of not
revealing quite enough or not explaining
quite enough
um while I did get the gist of what was
going on I felt like it needed a little
bit more expansion a little bit more
depth a little bit more like history
behind it
um the ending too was a little bit
abrupt I kind of felt like it left a lot
of things hanging or a lot of things
unexplained
um that I kind of wish had been resolved
a little bit better also I have to say
like there was a lot of character
establishment like at the beginning of
the story story which is normally what
you would do but like for example like
there was a kind of a big deal made
about Robbie the uncle like him breaking
up with his girlfriend and then him
having like all this anxiety about
having to ask Richard to stay at the
house with them so like there was a
little bit about that and that was kind
of gone into and then there was like
some stuff about Paisley the 13 year old
girl and her ambivalent feelings about
this boy
um like an older boy named Brent in
their old Hometown who she had been
texting and wanted to have sex with her
and she like just had these weird
feelings about it like she kind of like
hated him and missed him it's like they
kind of went a lot into that but neither
of these things like doesn't amount to
any like neither of these things amount
to anything or they don't play into the
unfolding story at all like despite how
much attention is paid to those things
like in the First Act of the novel and
there also seemed to be like a lot of
neat ideas that were introduced but not
really I guess like not sufficiently
followed up on like for example and I
think I alluded to this earlier but you
know there was a lot made at the
beginning about black Falls being this
town that was you know super up and
coming it's like turns up on all these
internet lists of like best places to
move this year blah blah blah and there
were a number of instances where
characters mentioned how this town was
like the best place ever and it's like
really growing and all this other kind
of stuff and I actually thought that
this was going to factor into the story
more going forward like what I was
thinking oh well whatever evil that
underpins this place or whatever
um it's planting suggestions in people's
heads and like sending tendrils out into
the world to draw people there but maybe
that was the intention but it wasn't
really like elaborated on like to any
great degree so I don't know if I'm just
like making that up and I have to say
too that while I absolutely loved the
whole setup of the neighbors leaving the
casseroles I don't know why that was so
creepy to me but it was
um the explanation for it it just kind
of like fell a little flat I felt I just
felt like oh that's it okay well that
does not I thought it was gonna be like
cooler than that you know what I mean
um and honestly it didn't really get
mentioned that much afterward I mean I
guess I just wish there had been more
backstory and like more concrete reasons
why certain things were happening I
mentioned earlier too that there were
numerous like POV changes in the
narrative as well which made the novel
read at times like a little bit like
kind of cluttered and unclear I mean I
don't have a problem with changes in POV
characters of course uh you know that
happens a lot but it's generally better
to start a new section when you're
inside the head of a new character
because that lessens confusion in your
reader obviously and this one was kind
of all over the place um it mostly
started out from Toby's perspective but
then would like switch on a dime to one
of his siblings or the other sibling or
you know one of his parents or his Uncle
Robbie and sometimes it would do that
like in the same paragraph
um it just kind of came across as
slightly muddled and sometimes I had to
read bits twice to make sure that I knew
who it was that's that was talking or
whose perspective we we were seeing
things from there were also like some
grammatical errors like some kind of
clunky like a little bit repetitive like
sentence structure that at times kind of
read a little bit like why a I'm not
really sure if that was the intention
um overall though I have to say it's I
know that it sounds like I'm [ __ ] on
it but it's like overall this was a
decent read um it had some intriguing
ideas and some really spooky set pieces
like I said I think the build up of it
was the best part I just kind of wish
that there had been maybe fewer
characters and like less pointless
character stuff and more stuff about the
town's history and like the nature of
this curse or whatever it is I kind of
wish that that had been elaborated on
more and I don't know I just kind of
wish there'd been like a little bit more
depth to it and some things like
explained better rather than focusing
too much on these kind of like teenagers
and their character relationships which
didn't really factor into the story like
going forward so that will do it for
this tomes of Terror and I will see you
guys again on the next one bye